[Musique]
et aujourd'hui je vous retrouve à
l'école win de Saint-Quentin en Evelin
c'est une école privée de management du
sport alors cette école elle dispense
des formations allant du bac + 1 au bac
+ 5 et ouvre de nombreuses opportunités
on peut devenir assistant d'athlète chef
de projet événementiel ou encore
commercial pour des grands comptes
sportifs alors si ces métiers vous
intéresse vous êtes au bon
[Musique]
endroit la journée démarre avec un cours
de marketing du sport à la fin du cours
les élèves devront réaliser une
présentation il a un groupe qui en train
de travailler sur un projet ça a l'air
intéressant donc on va aller les
voir
bonjour Petite question sur quoi est-ce
que vous êtes en train de travailler on
est en train de travailler sur un
dossier de sponsoring donc en fait notre
professeur nous a donné comme objectif
de prendre un club une structure
sportive donc nous on a pris le Paris
basketball et le but c'est d'aller
démarcher donc de prospecter des
partenaires et donc on doit monter un
dossier en conséquence pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi win comme école de
base je pense c'est commun à toute la
classe mais on est fan de sport donc du
coup même si on avait pas de projet en
tête le but c'était de travailler dans
le monde du sport c'est un peu la même
chose c'est-à-dire que je savais que je
pouvais pas aller en stat parce que je
voulais pas que ce soit trop
scientifique je voulais vraiment
professionnaliser la chose et c'est pour
ça que du coup j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
écoles de management du sport j'ai
atterré à win parce que c'était à côté
de chez moi donc c'était beaucoup plus
pratique donc ça m'a permis de
consolider mon parcours en faisant win
avec les différentes choses qui
proposent c'est-à-dire l'émission de
bénévola les stages et l'alternance et
aujourd'hui moi j'ai un projet de
développer mon auto-entreprise donc je
suis freeance dans l'événementiel et ça
me permet voilà de d'allier les deux
avec les études si vous aviez un métier
rêvé ce serait lequel du
coup moi je suis un passionné de
football depuis tout petit j'ai eu la
chance de participer à de à pas mal
d'événements notamment avec Fabien qui
m'a amené sur de nombreux événements de
football féminin je pense que l'idée un
événement de football féminin ou même de
football professionnel en tout cas dans
tous les cas professionnel ce serait un
rêve pour moi et et je pense pas
inatable donc c'est intéressant ça c'est
génial mais en tout cas c'est tout ce
que je vous souhaite merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'avoir répondu à ces questions
merci à vous merci à
[Musique]
vous et nous allons tout de suite
rejoindre Maxime Cola un intervenant en
management du sport il nous explique
comment il forme les étudiants au monde
professionnel bonjour maxi bonjour Vous
nous avez ramené des torches olympiques
exact et bah alors vous pouvez nous
raconter un peu leur histoire je sais
pas celle-là par exemple qui est en face
de moi elle est très belle c'est la
flamme des jeu de Los Angeles
1984 donc elle fait partie des rares
torches à avoir été allumé par Mohamed
Ali celle-ci c'est la flamme olympique
qui a été portée par Alexis vastin qui
était le porte-torche de la France pour
les Jeux de Pékin 2008 et vous avez ici
l'une des premières flammes des projets
privés de Pierre de Coubertin
potentiellement utilisé lors des Jeux de
Paris de 1924 vlez montrer également aux
étudiants c'est pour ramener un peu de
concret exactement c'est un projet que
j'ai développé où je me déplace dans les
villes laabéliser terre de jeu ou non où
j'ai développé des thématiques l'égalité
des chances le savoir vivre ensemble le
live skill donc c'est le savoir vivre
ensemble et donc ben je me déplace en
les exposant un petit peu pour parler de
leurs histoires pour parler des valeurs
pour parler de ce qu'elles représentent
et donc bah par rapport au cours que je
donne aux jeunes de Win aujourd'hui à
Saint-Quentin bah je les ai amené pour
le leur montrer un petit peu cette
rareté cette exclusivité c'est quel type
de projets sur lesquels les étudiants
peuvent travailler c'est les projets
d'aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on peut voir
sur la société comme par exemple les
projets en lien avec les Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 mais c'est aussi tous les
projets de demain parce que bah les
thématiques du jour c'est
l'accessibilité c'est l'égalité c'est le
développement durable et donc bah c'est
de faire comprendre un petit peu dans
les consciences de ce que les jeunes
connaissent aujourd'hui comment est-ce
qu'on peut apporter c'est ces
thématiques là dans notre quotidien dans
nos projets pro aussi et élaborer des
projets lien avec cette thématique là et
sur le marché on retrouve quoi comme
type de contrat c'est du CDI du CDD ça
peut être en indépendant auto
entrepreneur il faut être flexible à 100
% aujourd'hui on peut retrouver un petit
peu tout de plus en plus B il y a
énormément de jeunes qui souhaitent
monter leur société pour développer leur
propres projet et on a aussi bah
énormément de jeunes qui sont intéressés
par le monde institutionnel par exemple
donc les ministères ce genre de choses
mais aussi bah beaucoup le monde du
privé tout est possible c'est la force
aussi de Win
et voilà c'est la fin de cet épisode à
la windn Sport school vous avez pu
entendre Maxime Cola l'intervenant mais
également des étudiants j'espère que ces
témoignages vous auront éclairé si
jamais vous êtes intéressé par le
domaine du sport dans le monde
[Musique]
professionnel